so in the spinning district we saw that
an asymmetrically weighted disk
when spun actually flips so that the
lighter side goes towards the bottom now
this is a variation on something called
the tippy-top a little spinning toy that
spins upside down so that it's heavy
side actually lifts up now this toy was
played with by far more accomplished
physicists than me
people like Niels Bohr and Wolfgang
Pauli so I have a little confession to
make that when I made this spinning disc
video I didn't actually know how it
worked so when I said I don't want to
give you the answer right away what I
actually meant was can you guys help me
out and figure out how this works now in
the comments there were 25 comments
pertaining to centripetal force and 56
comments related to centrifugal force so
clearly I need to do a video about those
things I think most of the time you guys
were thinking an explanation like this
rotational systems teemed so that there
are mother of inertia increases so I'm
thinking that as this starts being like
this and is wobbling around we think
about there's a difference my granola or
this thing is spinning around compared
to at the bottom where there's more of
the meat
at the top the intuition is that takes
effort for the ice skater to bring her
arms in whereas just relaxing it tends
to increase its moment of inertia
through brutal force pushes it out now
an additional fifty two comments
mentioned inertia betting that that's my
answer for everything unfortunately I
don't think any of these things explains
really what's going on with the spinning
disk and so I had to set out and do my
own investigations so the first thing I
did was I talked to the smartest
physicists I know what do you think it's
going to do if I was going to spin round
and it's going to turn upside Dan says
the meshes up the top why is that I beg
of the by no wrong I filmed the disk in
a hundred frames per second and 300
frames per second slow motion and we
labeled some points along the disk so we
could really see what was happening but
even then it was tricky to figure out I
took it out to the ice rink to see what
role the surface played in terms of the
spinning discs so what is my final
explanation it is that when the disc is
spinning the first thing we should
notice is that the angular momentum
remains constant the whole time so when
I spin it clockwise from above the
angular momentum is pointing vertically
downwards and that remains the same even
as the disc flips over so what is
causing the disc to flip well if the
disc wobbles a little bit it's off
center so it's center of mass about
which it's spinning is not located
directly above the point of contact with
the surface and so as the disc spins
there's some sliding friction which acts
to create a torque on the disc
now that torque reduces the angular
momentum in the three direction of the
disc and increases it in the one two
direction of the disc which causes the
disc to turn over like this and once the
disc goes past that point the frictional
torque at the bottom continues to rotate
the disc until it is vertical like that
so it's really friction that is
responsible for flipping this disc over
so the heavy part goes up now there was
an excellent video response made by Zog
from beetlejuice so you should
definitely check that out why don't I
have any
hair in that anyway it is an amazing and
hilarious response which is actually
very physically accurate so check it out
when you get a chance now I have my
doubts that this explanation is really
the whole answer because I noticed that
if I spin it above the ground the whole
still seems to go towards the bottom
that's kind of odd and when I took you
the ice rink well sometimes the disc
would behave as expected and sometimes
it just did strange things where the
hole would go down and then up and then
down and then up I think maybe it's a
sign of precession or perhaps nutation
but those are things for another video
so until next time keep spinning those
discs